all of you out there following your
heart and the thing that you're good at
the thing you love it's costing you
freedom
oh man I'm a good photographer man
that's what I'm gonna do yeah so what
what if it doesn't pay anything you're
not going to survive in the jungle being
a small animal by yourself get out of
maybe stay at a maybe land if you can
get your customer to maybe that's good
you guys need to stay out of maybe land
need motivation watch the top ten would
believe nation what's that believe
nation it seven my one word is believe
and I believe in you I believe you have
Michael Jordan level talent add
something and I want you to find it
embrace it and use it to make a
difference so let's get your motivation
to attend and get you believing in you
grab a snack and join today's lessons
from a man who went from struggling with
a DD drugs and addiction growing up and
almost dying to becoming a best-selling
author top sales expert and having over
five hundred million dollars in real
estate
he's Grant Cardone and here's my take on
his top ten rules to success volume
seven also if you want to know what
Grant Cardone and other successful
entrepreneurs have to say about boosting
your confidence check out my 250 for
confidence series where every day for
the next 254 days I will send you a 30
second to five minute video for free
helping you build unstoppable confidence
check out the details in the description
below where do you get your
self-confidence
you can buy it at the store folks can't
dress it up can't eat it you can't buy
it
you can't even manufacture it yourself
you have to go build self-confidence
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one get the right data who do you work
with live with hang with that's causing
you to put a break when you accelerate
this is a huge issue okay this is a
mental issue totally mental totally
about who's playing in your Park in your
business park
who's telling you oh by the way there
could be somebody you sleep with it
could be it could be the information
your kids are bringing from school it
could be your mom and dad it could be
all those it could be the paper you're
reading the Instagram you're watching
the Facebook you're looking at it could
be all that you know you get advice for
me and you and you go flip over to Dave
Ramsey you're gonna see this conflict
like okay grants using debt Dave's not
who's right so pick somebody and go deep
with that person we if you're gonna pick
a mentor one of the biggest questions I
get is who like how do I pick a mentor
you are you got to get rid of mentor so
you guys already have too many you
listen to everybody an open mind is not
always a good thing when when a
parachute when a parachute opens like
this we're good a wide open mind means
this I take information from anybody and
everybody what you want to do is like
this like you want to run the race with
blinders on get your data if I have a
long piece of data that I'm stable on
I'm probably gonna be more effective
than a right piece of data that I'm
unsure about rule number two get a herd
number two I would quit being small the
first thing you said I'm a small company
you're not gonna make it you can't make
it it's impossible you're not going to
survive in the jungle being a small
animal by yourself what animal does this
everybody in the room if you're trying
to stay small you will die the reason
you're staying small is because you
won't spend money and the reason you
won't spend money is because somebody
got up in your head and said hey man
money is scarce it's the problem there's
no shortage of money on this planet bro
you need to go get some money take them
money invested in people right you need
to get heard around you you need to get
it heard around you so that when the
tiger comes the elephants but yeah - do
you come all by yourself I stupid look
at us right so so you need to get a herd
man okay and you need to train the herd
to protect to defend to feed to hunt and
so that's all over tell you got to get
you got to get a posse you got to get
you got any gonna start thinking I'm a
how big can I get rule number three
invest in marketing when I started my
business I'd get money and I'd save it
I'd get money not say about get money
not save it and I didn't spend money and
marketing and branding so when I was
writing the 10x rule I'm like dude why
am I not bigger than I'm I've been
busting my ass working so hard I've been
pushing and shoving I have the best
products of any anybody in my space I
know I have the biggest the biggest
platform of products in the best
problems why Wyatt why are other guys
kicking my ass and I'm like dude you you
haven't reinvested the money and
marketing and branding right I was not
spending money I look at the mattress
guy in Boston I look at the car dealer
in Boston Herb Chambers out Smith
everybody crushes the the mattress got
out spins everybody the might the my
pillow guy on TV he who knows what he
spends he might spend a hundred million
dollars a year in advertising to get a
billion in I'm like oh my god dumb-dumb
mm-hmm you didn't market and you didn't
advertise so this month we'll spend
probably a million dollars on
advertising on advertising rule number
four find the real you my whole life
I've been told
what that means to be myself in fact I
would tell you it's probably bad advice
one of the come someone else look if I
was just gonna be who I am who I was you
know grant just be yourself I'd still be
in Lake Charles Louisiana I'd have a job
and I had 30 years ago nothing wrong
with that job but if I was just gonna be
myself whatever that means exactly you
really need to ask yourself what does it
mean what are some of these little
quaint very common sayings mean every
time I hear a comment saying something
that the masses agree with I think to
myself is that true just be yourself
just be yourself just be broke just be
lazy just be your problem your handicap
your issue your weakness your one Street
just be that I don't think so I think
we're all meant to be a lot more than
that we're pretending to be right now
you have to become someone else before
you even discover who you really are
promise you this is true you're gonna
have to it comes someone else what the
real you you don't know that person yet
he's here she's been over educated or
under educated one of the two it's not
nothing you didn't get the perfect
amount of education to actually become
who you are because colleges and the
school systems don't teach you how to
find and discover the real you I've
spent I don't know thirty years of my
life just just stripping away at the
parts of me that aren't me
the poor Louisiana boy the middle-class
boy the I gotta save all my money boy
you know I got it I got a I can't trust
people stay tight stay close stay small
don't get too big don't get too much
attention I had to strip all that boy
away by the way there's been hundreds of
layers of false information wrong
information incorrect data assumed
identities by the way I was in a no
isn't operating like a junkie in an
alcoholic for years told that alcoholism
and drug addiction ran in my family and
I somehow adopted this just be yourself
see if I was still just being myself
whatever that means I'd still be a
junkie okay I decided to become the me
I'm supposed to be rule number five get
brand visibility whatever you're doing
is level one level two level three if it
doesn't include Facebook and IG and
YouTube and Robert kiss show him hey man
I got you on all these platforms bro
we're spending money like crazy over
here okay so does he need ROI right now
he needs visibility he does not need it
he's not gonna get ROI right now okay he
his ROI is going to be visibility okay
he needs visibility on investment voi
and he'll get dollars later you want to
go on you want to go on Fox News I've
been on Fox News 50 times there's kind
of not gonna be any return on investment
but there's gonna be visibility on your
investment of time and energy right so
he thinks but these people don't know
that they think they want money right he
can't get money until he gets visibility
is what I say about nobody's gonna flow
you until they know you and he knows
that's true okay so you just got to keep
going back to him and saying dude we're
getting your brand visibility okay we're
gonna get you domination on search that
costs time energy and money this guy
y'all need to be working on articles for
this guy okay I would be looking at
article
posting twice a day watch what I'm doing
with card on capital every day
personally LinkedIn Facebook snapchat
Instagram little short stories about why
Cardone capitals of a great place to
invest every day I'm pounding that
message out this is what this guy wants
even though he's gonna tell you he wants
level 1 level 2 level 3 level 4 and all
that but you guys are going to be a
level 1 with this cat for a long time
and he will get his money's worth okay
if you can touch level 2 level 3 level 4
whatever they are okay if you can just
touch it that'd be great
but you need to spend your time and
energy in level 1 rule number 6 my
personal favorite stay out of maybe land
the length of time between the idea and
the execution is gonna determine how
much money you guys make get out of
maybe stay out of maybe land if you can
get your customer to maybe that's good
you guys need to stay out of maybe land
maybe land is where doubt lives doubt
slows down the organization oh god what
do I do
first time I met Jared Jared it'd been
in my office three or four weeks working
first time I met him I walked up who you
meant I'm Jared what are you doing here
I'm making a list that's it dude I don't
pay you to make a list make a call okay
you got an idea to come work for me pick
up the phone and call somebody because
that list will not pay you the only
thing that's gonna pay you as the call
right so I'm not planning I'm producing
we don't spend enough time at my company
planning so this is what does what
happens at our company okay and I look
we don't do everything right there
most the time this is what happens I
have an idea
okay look I got I got a lot of ideas how
many ever we got a lotta ideas okay that
idea is only as good as you can monetize
that idea otherwise it's worth nothing
the faster I can monetize this idea the
better that idea is how many agree with
that so I go for my idea to monetization
we're gonna be going over this later
today this is what you do you go from an
idea to planning I go at idea landing
page by button put a price on it not
even a picture of a product so how long
is it taking you to go from an idea to
monetization and by the way how many
people are involved there was two people
involved we have 85 people at my company
I didn't involve anybody else the more
people you involved if you're taking
notes the more people you involve the
longer it is going to take to get to a
delivery a deliverable product I don't
need more ideas I need execution
planning not production you're spending
time planning thinking ideas buy-in get
everybody's input I want everybody to
feel good about it dude I don't care
about any of that I didn't check with
anybody okay I can be wrong on my own I
know right I don't need I don't need to
spend time and be wrong let me just get
to wrong as fast as I can rule number
seven follow the money you need to go
get money like you don't have to go do a
job to get money you need to go connect
with money like you need you need to sit
down and understand what kind of money
you're looking for you guys all of you
out there following your heart and the
thing that you're good at the thing you
love it's costing you freedom
oh man I'm a good photographer man
that's what I'm gonna do yeah so what
what if it doesn't pay anything what if
you good at milking cows ain't nobody
paying for milk anymore but I'm so good
at yeah I love it okay so you're good at
you're good at what's that second job
you got and teaching Spanish and English
yeah man it's a hard deal to scale bro
like like I you know you're selling time
for money you're trading time for money
yeah so if I were
you'll be a nanny to rich people teach
my kids how to speak Chinese man I'll
pay I'll pay 50 bucks an hour for that
what are those people paying you oh by
the way I'll give you five hours twice a
week what do you get for a class right
now no no like here it's more or less
like 1520 dollars yeah exactly because
you're doing it to the wrong public you
need to go to somebody's gotta that that
wants to learn and and and you know you
got to figure out first of all you got
to do the calculation you guys need to
start doing calculations financial
calculations there is nothing wrong with
follow the money who's got the money man
that's that t-shirt who's got my damn
money right who made you a hundred
dollars an hour bro you're just calling
on the wrong people folks rule number
eight think long term
five grand is the doable deal how do I
do it it's four hundred and twelve
dollars a month okay
I got to go steal the money I can steal
five that you could steal five grand for
me and I wouldn't even know it's gonna
be like if you could add five thousand
of that and earn 20% it'd be worth a
million 125 if you can do this at ten
percent of be worth 320 some of you
small thinkers out there be like dude
I'll take two 320 how do I get ten and
how do I get twenty you guys have
figured this out you're like if the play
is big enough dude I'll figure that out
everybody agree see see what I just I
shifted your mind by giving you a target
I don't go to target I get targets and I
keep targets and i refresh the target
and the target is I want to be a
millionaire but over the period of time
I got 20 years by the way what would pay
me 20 percent a year over 20 years and
that is when your boy GC got rich I
didn't get rich speaking I didn't get
rich selling books I got rich shopping
real estate 30 years old shopping every
weekend dude every weekend all I did
between 25 and 30 years old was make
money make money make money and push it
aside push it aside push it aside even
when in the first years when I was not
watch this
even when I was not 25 years old five
grand boom next year five grand boom
next year five grand the boom
guess what next year oh by the way this
money's sitting dead in the bank it's
not not owning anything it's it's in a
it's in a holy account holy means okay
I'm gonna put a hole in your face if you
touch my money nobody could get this
money this is a like sacred account okay
you with me
28 oh wow man I could add a little bit
maybe there's more money 29 what am i
doing right here okay one two three four
boom I got $25,000 sitting in account it
wasn't a million dollars and I'm five
years into the plan but when I was ready
to start investing money I started doing
my homework thirty years old
homework shopping properties 31 homework
shopping properties 32 I'm not buying
cars you guys are buying cars flying on
jet charters showing off going on
vacations all I'm doing is stacking
paper guess what happens I have 5 years
of putting 5 grand away next thing you
know I had $25,000 to add to my twenty
five thousand dollars next year I'm
making more money I got twenty five
thousand dollars you see what I'm doing
a stacking dough and looking for 20
percent I know there's a 20% play out
there some of this money was sitting in
the bank this is years and years to go
with the banquet pay me six or seven or
eight it didn't matter that's not the
target the target is to get to 1 million
remember this and let's open up the call
us okay your job is to find a vehicle
they can pay you 20% a year might be a
business might be the business you're in
it might be to buy advertising for the
business of ran urine for me it was this
I'm in a bad real estate that over long
periods of time I will earn cash flow
okay that's how the real estate works
I put $25,000 in a deal that deal is
probably gonna pay me 10% a year you
said yeah but grant you said would you
say grant would you say
20% grand that's what you said yeah I
know what I said just say Neddy okay now
how much do I have
I could reinvest that money back into
the deal the next year I have twenty
seven thousand five hundred dollars
I earn ten percent on that that's twenty
seven fifty or something like that
I reinvest that now I've got thirty
thousand in the deal hey but what you
don't know is the rent on this property
as I own it over 20 years two thousand
thirty eight we'll dispose of this thing
the rent is going up as I'm adding money
the rents going up and maybe this goes
from ten percent a year by the time I
sell I want to be a twenty percent okay
my average deal has paid me over 30
percent of years so when you start
taking money and start compounding it
like that for long periods of time the
trick is long periods of time rule
number nine studies success if you study
the most successful people that you know
in any business the Warren Buffett's in
finance the LeBron James in basketball
you just start studying I've been
studying since I was since my dad died
my dad died when I was ten years old and
I needed Mentors
and you can't go get another dad
my uncle's they weren't that they had
their own life going on so they they
couldn't mentor me so I was like well
who are these people and we all we all
have examples the problem today in
America is the example it's getting more
and more average it's good we're
becoming an epidemic of mediocrity so if
you study the really really you know
exuberant ly successful people they're
gonna have some traits in common
obsessed if you've ever met a great
sales manager a great sales person great
used-car manager great finance manager
they're obsessed they read study learn
eat it you know they're obsessed people
see obsession in our culture though is
not a good thing if you when you hear
the word obsession you start thinking
the guy's got a problem
obsessive-compulsive disorder look if
you're not getting labeled if people are
not labeling you in society as a freak
case then you're not successful whatever
goal you want let's say you have a
financial goal even though that's just
one goal you know you'd have life
spiritual if your family your marriage
how much action do you need to take and
rule number 10 the last one before a
very special bonus clip is have fun
people think I'm crazy I think I'm
saying
I'm back in the states going crazy crazy
look whether you're playing in Euros or
you playing in dollars it's time to get
your money right you know that's right
so give me back a holla
the whole thing's joke man it's all a
joke okay
you guys put too much emphasis on money
I'm actually the one that thesis all
funny that's why I end up with the
dollars and honey
through the sky that's right dreaming
big
I'm not selfish like a pig I'm here to
share I'm not scared of
nobody I want to help you cross the
ocean body because I want to come see
you I want to know everybody you got you
got you
[Music]
now I've got a really special bonus
grant cardone clip on why you must
invest in real estate but before that
the three questions I want to make sure
you're moving from a spot of just
consuming content to actually being
reflective and making a difference
making some change happen in your life
your business so here we go
question number one how can you get a
better herd of people around you
question number two where are you going
to increase your marketing efforts this
week and question number three what is
keeping you in maybe Lane and how will
you overcome it thank you guys so much
for watching I believe in you I hope we
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you soon and enjoy the bonus clip
work hard
even the things that is
but the third thing again
and investing it
speculative
these are wealthy people either there
they're very wealthy companies
they keep investing
that's what apartments do that's what
office building
in the right location
it's like making an investment in you
desirable today
with a great place to live
that's how all these people they either
started in real estate
for their money ends up in realist
the money that I've accumulated
it is a single only thing that separates
me from other people that have worked
hard and found
and I invested hard assets that
appreciate over time and
and then when you waste a little money
we can go
we can buy stuff dick that goes down in
with assets
in value
altruistic world domination
honey Empire right I'm grateful I
understand why I'm here I think because
I am so open I wanted to think and say
it's a bloody brief life all of you have
the potential for enormous success if
you want to know what Gary Vee DJ Khalid
Oprah and others know about empire
building that most people miss check out
the link in the description for a free
bonus video